how different is how different is
uh what was going on then versus now
because i so so for me i watched two
documents i watched ukraine on fire i
watched winter on fire so winter on fire
was the one sean penn talks about the
crate on fire yeah yours is ukraine on
fire there's another one that says
fire
and so i watched both of them because i
want to kind of get a feeling
winter on fire is more about the
students the revolution hey victor
agreed yes we're going to sign the eu
agreement we're going to go with them
everything's going to work out overnight
he says no i'm going to go to russia so
the students revolt and they're you know
all those scenes it's very emotional
stuff to watch but you watch that so
then i'm going to go and watch yours
because winter on fire doesn't tell the
history of ukraine it doesn't tell the
history of what
did you know you know who he was and how
80 000 ukrainians ukrainian soldiers
represented and fought for hitler and
then they put him in jail and then you
know the the the two victors battling
and the role russia played it was a very
interesting way of seeing ukraine on
fire what what did you learn
about ukraine and russia when you did
the documentary ukraine on fire
because we're in it right now we're into
this also you have there's antecedents
here among other things you should go
back to world war ii and you should
understand that there's a split in the
ukraine and that
part half of ukraine is russian speaking
the other half
is anti-russian strongly so
stephen bandera and people like that
were working with the nazis
many groups
the ukrainians were
uh hunting jews in in ukraine and in uh
poland there was a lot of killing going
on it was a dirty bloody war so much
stuff happened that
so
you have all these people they never
went away they're still there in the
ukraine if you look at the maidan
the maidan moment and you look at our
film you'll see very clearly the nazi
the neo-nazis are back the azov
battalion the idaho battalion uh the
right sector party and and you see them
on camera and they're very rough
customers these people they're not about
to be they don't believe in democracy
they don't believe yeah there was a lot
of students and a lot of honest people
in my dad and there was a lot of
frustration with the corruption
in ukraine
but we go into the whole history of that
relationship of
the president with the eu he tried to
make a deal with the eu he had a better
economic deal from russia that's that's
the reason he stayed
he didn't sign on to the eu deal very
important to recognize that he wanted to
postpone it until he got a better deal
and that makes sense too
when all this was happening in my dan he
even offered to have an earlier election
he offered it he said
if you want to okay you want to get rid
of me it's not democratic but we'll
we'll go with an earlier election
and they actually accepted it but then
the these thugs who are operating behind
the scenes at maidan
very organized by the way very organized
i think the cia plays another role there
because cia has been involved with
ukrainian nazis since world war ii we
got a lot of them out to our country on
the rat lines and we came back
after world war ii and 48 there was a an
operation by the cia to drop these
people into ukraine to make trouble to
start
troubles for uh russia
it's an old story it's not new you know
this is but i don't think a lot of
people know it though well it's an it's
a fact in fact the guy i worked with on
jfk fletcher prouty was a colonel who
was in the world war ii and air force
and he was one of those guys who
supplies these these uh
uh infiltrate infiltrators to the
ukraine with weapons
and with flights and you have to drop
them and so forth and so on it's a lot
of hardware all these guys were picked
up by the way that's what's amazing that
we are in it's like with castro whenever
we go up against castro he seems to find
out the people we send in uh secretly
it's an interesting side effect but the
russians picked up
the russian ukraine picked up these
people but we tried to destroy russia
by any chance do you know if your phone
is on because someone's ring is going oh
i'm doing this you mean is your phone on
do you have your phone with you maybe
it's your phone going on because
someone's phone's going off
i have it with me but i check to see if
maybe if it's going up okay uh just the
ringtone no it's nothing okay sounds
good
so so so so now if we watch tv today and
we turn it on you you're seeing uh
zelinski that is standing and he's you
know looking pretty strong and tough and
he's not you know reacting and the news
is telling us that russia's lost five to
six thousand soldiers uh in the last few
weeks which is more than what we lost in
iraq and
you know the the two foreign ministers
had a conversation together two three
days ago it was an hour and a half
conversation in turkey nothing uh no
advancements really made
how different is ukraine's story today
versus when you did the documentary how
much has changed because zelinski is not
in your documentary when you did it
right so is it night and day different
story today are they making more
problems we didn't no it's not me who
did it
the director was igor lapatonic who was
ukrainian
russian ukrainian and he did it i was an
interviewer and a pr one of the
producers so
these two films ukraine on fire and
the other one is called uh ukraine
revealed
revealed goes into the present moment
with zelinski there
it's a very interesting documentary
about the opposition candidate victor
medvedek medvedchuk
victor medvedchuk
revealing ukraine that's it
robert perry was one of the great
journalists in our country it was the
most eloquent about ukraine and and saw
this coming he was talking about a
nuclear conflict back in 2014
when this thing went down he saw it
coming he died in 2015 it's a great loss
to american journalism he was the truth
teller
this story is
today is so passionate and so
complicated all the news in america
unfortunately is
is one-sided you don't get anything from
the other side there's no and they
banned it they banned rt and they banned
right they had a very concerted campaign
to cut off what they call russian
disinformation is perhaps the best
information we can get from what's
really going on
and i frankly i don't have all the
details i do hear the other side because
i read alternate media which is to say
what's available on the internet they're
not going to be able to kill off all
that
because there are a lot of american
journalists who are aware of this and
writing about it there are people who
actually been in donbass and can tell
you that in from 2014 to now don bass
has been victimized by
the ukrainian army and especially by the
nazis the neo-nazi gangs they're the
ones who've been dropping the artillery
killing people
it's been a bloody and it's hard there's
estimated 16 000 dead
most of them on the russian side most of
them uh don bass people
okay and that is never dealt with you
don't hear about it in the u.s media can
you pull up danvest on the map by the
way a lot of them have immigra because
of the bombings they move they
immigrated to russia across the border
and uh you don't hear about that you'll
hear about refugees only going to the
other side from this war i don't think
it's an uh listen i don't know what
putin had putin
pune is uh was squeezed he was provoked
into this thing and that's the truth the
united states has using ukraine
as an as a proxy
to put pressure they don't us doesn't
care about ukraine they care about
russia this is a chance to destabilize
russia remove the leader regime change
once again on a big on a big way there's
a big victory for them if they can pull
it off
and this was always the gold from the
beginning i i don't think there's any
concern about the ukrainian people
except as a sentimental thing in the
newspaper as well this person was killed
that person was killed but what about
the people who were killed on the other
side they never mentioned them for five
six years no more than that eight years
those people were killed too families
were killed
um
you know it's it's crazy what you're
saying so let me let me give you a
different perspective from my from my
life
so when i lived in iran if you turn on
the news in iran we have two channels
uh every president in iran in the u.s
was the enemy you heard death upon
america you heard about how big of an
enemy
everybody was except for people in iran
so you we were naive we thought khomeini
was the greatest thing since sliced
bread we thought khomeini imam khamenei
these guys were all right and the show
was horrible the show was a
horrible person in iran i mean if you
said anything good about the sean iran
you're a bad person right so then you
come to
we go live in germany and you watch
satins in germany okay satins is like
their nbc let's just say right you're
watching satins and you're saying who
they paint as being a bad person right
and they're painting the picture of
who's what right then you come to the
states you turn on the news and you hear
who the enemy is right here
you know and then and then eventually
you got to get to point that either
you're going to follow the masses and if
they're believing what they're believing
we got to question some of it right so
us carter what they did which was
seems like very interesting strategy
that they're currently using here as
well this is a very easy playbook to use
is
they used khomeini who was in france
a way to get the shot to be out so
carter goes to iran has a nice little
dinner with the shah december 31 77 they
do a toast gives a toast leaves
revolution happens right off the bat i'm
born in 78 october
18th
kissinger keeps saying we're going to
help you we're going to help you we're
going to help you we're going to help
you then the last thing they tell them
is we'll help to take you out and he
leaves
you know in january february something
second khomeini takes over and then iran
right away there's a war between iraq
now u.s doesn't get then there's i so we
do
get involved we do get involved with the
point and then who makes money the
military-industrial complex you know all
these raytheon northrop grumman but but
the point is
that there is there is rarely a way to
know the whole story you just said
something right now that the audience is
going to sit there and say wait u.s is
using ukraine as a proxy to get to putin
to remove him because now the whole
world hates that guy didn't want to move
him okay what was your experience like
when you did your interview with putin
yeah
i'll tell you in a second but
just to make one more point about iran
to me the whole thing uh devolves back
to 1953
when they got the invention ucia and
british intelligence got rid of mozadeg
he was the democratic choice for prime
minister he was very popular among most
people in iran and he would have won and
he would have kept going and he
nationalized part after a lot of
provocation he nationalized the oil
interests the british oil interests
particularly in iran that was his
that was the signal to get rid of them
so they used ci very heavily involved
they they paid money to mobs to storm
the streets to create all these
distractions like they did in maydown to
bring
chaos to the country and then in the
chaos he was called a communist again he
was not a communist because of the
two-day party he did have contacts but
he was not a communist he was more like
a bernie sanders he was he was more of a
socialist he was not accountable he was
a social man he was a great man yeah
he was just too trusting he trusted too
much and
they got rid of him they didn't kill him
but they they've been like they removed
him yeah and they put the shot in again
they'd done that before
and deshaw of course became more and
more of a tyrant and a lot of torture i
went to the prison there i saw all the
the stories of the torture they're very
famous in iran a lot of people are
scared
to open their mouths under the shah and
of course khomeini comes in he was not
the people's choice he was definitely a
counter he was because of the extremism
of the shah that's you get another
extreme reaction to that that always
happens in history it does very rarely
can a moderate emerge in this world
khamenei was extreme and
whatever you you know you know the the
rest of the story
uh
however khomeini did have a lot of
provocation we went on the iran iraq
side of the war we supported iraq
at first
we gave them weapons and then we when
reagan wanted help with the contras
in latin america to defeat the
nicaraguan communists
he gave weapons he gave weapons to iran
which is to a khomeini's regime this is
amazing this is 1983
82 right
right off the cardinal dirty story i
mean reagan was a tr
basically had done something that the
worst american i mean
it's trade it's an act a traitor you
mean you're supporting the supposed
enemy
nixon in watergate never did anything
close to what reagan did reagan got away
with it because he was popular in a
sense he had that smile he's a good
performer contra gate is one of the most
undiscovered scandals in american
history country if you should really
read up on it it's a very important
scandal and it comes it comes unglued
and reagan in the last two years of his
life his presidency was unable to
uh was unable to uh
keep his agenda going in fact we would
have been in we would have been in a war
in nicaragua he would have sent troops
to nicaragua i was down in that region
because i was visiting it to make
salvador my first one of my first movies
i was in that region i saw all the
troops in honduras i saw the troops in
el salvador
there was quite there was an operation
about to happen and thank god iran
contra gate was blown among them was
robert perry who blew the story
changed the direction of the country
briefly
all these stories
we we heard about him we heard about
this from oliver north and all the
hearings looking as a very
colonel that's that was the portrayal
right oliver north was one of the uh
malefactors yes he was one of reagan's
men but it goes back to reagan he got
away with it north took a fall as do as
you know how many people resigned in
iran conjugate about six people
mcfarland there was a whole bunch of
people who resigned i forgot exactly who
reagan uh
he basically uh skated out of there two
years later by the way all these stories
that you're bringing up which are
and so did george h.w bush bush was
definitely involved in negotiations with
the iranians
he got out too i mean this whole thing
was buried and you have to point to the
washington media here i'm sorry but i'm
just going to finish the story but
washington post plays a huge role here
catherine graham who was the
famous star meryl streep player in the
post miss hero of america all that kind
of stuff she she buried the story
she did not believe after watergate the
post had been involved in watergate she
said i don't think america can take a
second shock like this so she killed it
killed the story there was no coverage
i was just gonna say that all these
stories that you're bringing up which
are not easy on the ears if you're
obviously pro-american the one
visualization that i'm having is the
whole scene from trump's interview in
2016 where he famously says
oh you think we're that innocent too
what was the one thing that he said
it's the one honest thing that trump
says you said possibly
okay but it's true i mean essentially
you're taking you're going inside the
underbelly of america the cia and you
know what's happening in the oval office
and you know these secret conversations
and you're bringing and you're shining a
light on them and it's not so pretty
even if you love america it's hard to
digest i love america and i can take
this
i can take the dirt i think that's what
we have to do we have to be truthful and
we can be better people we can on and we
can treat other people with
respect
and understand our limitations as well
it's
why do we have to be top dog is a big
question
well that's that's american
exceptionalism right i mean that's the
concept of capitalism there's
competition that's in the core dna that
we have here this is why america has
40 million immigrants that they want to
come here and have an equal opportunity
to compete in a marketplace and if you
can you can build a great life for
yourself but you can't have a
capitalistic society and then ask people
why are we so competitive to be number
one it's like if you play for the
yankees the yankees don't start the
season saying guys listen let's just
play the game forget about going to play
who cares about the playoffs let's just
win to play the game that's not the
yankees nature yankees are starting a
season to say let's crush everybody and
win
the world series
the yankees a lot of these guys so if
you enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]
you